[Music]
how did clint stumble into grounding and
become one of its most prominent experts
okay that starts a long time back but i
have to build into it a little bit yeah
yeah but i i grew up in montana
and
as a as a child or as a young boy
i um
i was a cowboy and that's a boy who sits
on a horse and
rides along with the cows and
sometimes you're out there for two or
three days but basically you're keeping
an eye on the cows to make sure they're
they're healthy and happy
and it's important if they're not happy
they get scared and they run then you
gotta
find some problems but anyhow to make
you know you you watch the animals to
make sure they're not glassy eyed or
that they're acting differently than the
rest any of the rest of the herd and if
there is an issue then you pull them out
of the herd put them in a little holding
pin
and then you go ride the pasture and
make sure there's no noxious weeds
make sure the grass is not too short
make sure the water's clean make sure
there's not a dead animal upstream
contaminating the stream and so on but
there's something in that pasture that's
affecting that cow because there's you
know so the concept is
keep the pasture clean and pristine and
you will have health oh wow so that's
where i come from and it's so prevention
back when i was a kid we had a magazine
called prevention magazine
and eat an apple a day keep the doctor
away so everything was about prevention
and and you know health assurance
do the things that are going to keep you
healthy and and whole
and so anyhow i grew up with that and
then i have a lot of when i was younger
i had a lot of native american friends
so they teach a whole different
reality than
you know the angelo
uh commercial yeah the traditional
western world right yeah yeah yeah we're
all mixed up over here yeah and i i
always tell people i said you know the
native americans and these are native
americans 60 70 years ago but you know
they lived um
somewhere between the earth and
the sky up here but they but they're
more of a
uh
i i don't know if spiritual is there
they're
but they're they're just more connected
to nature connected to each other and
it's a oneness that
but it's not something that exists in
the anglo world yeah um
so anyhow um
that kind of set the tone for you know i
was young that's who i am i'm a
naturist naturalist if i don't see it in
nature i don't really buy it or believe
it
um and um
and health is our most natural state you
know in nature
i mean to be all hobbled up and beat up
and sick and whatever that's that
doesn't exist in the animal world yeah
animals that live in nature
uh they don't have cardiovascular
disease they don't have
lupus ms fibromyalgia oh wow cancer the
cancer rarely exists in the natural
world
okay on the other hand animals who live
indoors with their owners insulated from
the earth
they manifest the same health disorders
as their own there's diabetes and you
know a host of autoimmune disease and 50
of them die from cancer just like their
owners
wow
so i have that little bit of
knowledge that
to younger people it's kind of like
excuse me what are you talking about
but
uh the animal world is where i draw a
lot of and nature is where i draw a lot
of information but anyhow after growing
up in that environment i
i fell in love with the cable television
industry
and the reason was because i was living
in montana where we had one station or
two stations
we lived in montana for five or six
years so we i met my wife out there yeah
and what i'll say is that um
that industry is also an industry that
ryan and i worked in albeit back in ohio
so yeah and and so tell us about how
that exposed you to the even the concept
of grounding well that's yeah i could go
for an hour and talk about why i fell in
love with various things you know i was
one of the first people to put data over
satellite and feed it to a personal
computer but anyhow that whole industry
aside from all of
you know what
what was driving me was it it's an
industry where everything has to be
grounded
to prevent um and to maintain electrical
stability to prevent static noise
uh like the cable lines telephone cable
whatever the wind blows there's dust
that creates static charges there's
lightning in the air it can travel down
the lines go into the home and blow up a
tv set and start a fire so what we're
talking about is fire
grounding is related to fire oh wow and
um
but yeah everything has to be grounded
in our homes
and it's all it's all about preventing
fire
and most people are not aware of that
um so but anyhow i i so i have a
background a working knowledge of
grounding
and you know you drive a stake in the
ground and you take a cable and splice
it and connect to one side of the ground
block and then another the other one
goes into the house where you're
intercepting any lightning and driving
it to the to the ground
you know in order to prevent fire so
anyhow
that's
i have a 30 year working background of
just mechanical grounding for
uh electrical stability of communication
systems and and the like
and
when i turned 50
um 49 you know oh there's 20 20 a long
time ago anyway
i can't remember it was almost 30 years
ago yeah you told me you were 78 i was
wow yeah incredible so but anyhow um
i
i i when i was about 49 i went and had a
root canal done
and about a month later i started
getting turning yellow and getting sick
and nobody knew that it was related but
anyhow i ended up in
the emergency room after 30 days the
docs kept testing every week they would
run a test then i'd go back and say well
it's not that so then i was getting
sicker and sicker and so they didn't
really know what it was they thought it
could have been hepatitis b
they couldn't validate that so anyhow i
got really sick and i ended up in the
hospital
or in a icu or emergency room whatever
ended up with all all of the above
anyhow i went in and
they put me in a cat scan and found out
i had an abscess in my liver
and that was and they asked me if i had
been bitten i said no they said have you
had any dental surgery i said yes
because the bacteria they cultured was
from the mouth oh wow and so anyhow they
while i was in the cat scan they stuck a
big needle about 12 inches long into my
side right here and pushed it into the
liver and drained all of the abscess
from the liver
and
it was a lot of pain anyway but anyhow
the next morning they came in a um
uh infectious disease doc because that's
who we had they had assigned me to he
said well we got some good news the bad
news we know what it is
uh it was from your dental thing and so
on and the bad news is that you are only
49
and you're young enough to get a new
liver you're not an alcoholic or
anything but you don't have time
so you need to go home and get your act
together
and um
you know prepare for the worst wow and
that was a shock that was like that was
like getting hit with the truck you know
and so anyhow i went home and they had a
nurse come daily and uh had an iv they
would
you know give me every antibiotic in the
world about it a week 10 days later a
swedish medical center in denver called
and they had a young surgeon who wanted
to do experimental surgery
so it's kind of hard to explain the
uh the liver and everything without
pictures and stuff but anyhow
they decided to go in and cut out 5 6 of
the main lobe of my liver they didn't
they had no idea if i could survive it
because that's not very much yeah and so
anyhow i did survive
and you know they kept me up took the
liver out cut it out and put it back in
there sewed it up and said that's all we
can do
wow and i did wake up a day later in icu
and there's a whole story that goes with
that but not not here and
so anyhow i went home um you know a few
days later
and it took me several days to be able
to walk you know to the bathroom wow no
energy
and then so every day i just one more
step every day whatever so i eventually
uh was able to
walk a mile and six months later my
liver grew back 100 percent so i have a
28 year old liver that's awesome
[Music]
it's incredible so anyhow that's
but in during that process that's what
one of the things i love about your show
is one through that process
i woke up one morning
after recovering and i looked out the
window and i noticed that the the
pine trees were
vibrant they were energized and the sky
was a blue or blue and everything was
more energetic
and i i looked around the room and at
the end of the bed i had a earl bess
painting which is a famous western
artist
a native american
and it was like you know four feet by
four feet in but i had collected art i
had spent 50 years or more collecting
fine western art
and i had a 5 000 square foot bedroom 1
i mean 5 thousand square foot a frame
log cabin imagine a ski lodge
and full of art and it's a one bedroom
home
and so anyhow i was
on top of stanley mountain in evergreen
colorado i could see denver i could see
baal you know wow and so i was playing
king we all play king of the mountain so
when we're 50 you know that's our goal
is to drive everybody into the sea and
you know
and win the war you had achieved it all
yeah i had achieved it all
and that's where i hit the wall like
most men who are 50 years old they hit
the wall
autoimmune disease inflammation
cardiovascular so on they don't take
care of their self until they have their
first heart attack
and
so anyhow that's kind of
uh woke me up and i looked around
and i realized that everything in my
home all these things i loved and had
spent years and years collecting
and i almost died and what would have
happened to them i know that my kids
would one of them would have taken this
one of them would have taken that but
the majority of the nobody would have
wanted it
so he would have donated it or been
given away thrown away whatever and i
thought i mean it was just a shock such
a shocking thing yeah my system
that's when i i had this epiphany that i
i never really owned any of this stuff
all i ever did was collect it and take
care of it
and my life was about you know taking
care of these things it wasn't about my
life it wasn't about doing something
worthwhile even though i had done some
things that were worthwhile
but it was so it just you know shocked
me to the course so i called all my
children i said i want you to come and
get whatever you would have taken if i
would have died
and take it now and that way it's not
because anything else i'm going to give
it away
and so one of my daughters called the
doctor and said he needs to see a shrink
there's something wrong with him
my dad's lost it and i went to see the
shrink you know you know just out of
whatever
and and i told him i said no this is
real i don't want to own anything i have
this chill in me
when i think of owning something i have
to have certain things but
i don't want to own it i don't want to
be responsible for it i don't want to
care for it i don't want to do anything
i want to be able to free be free
but the main thing is when i almost died
i recognized some of this and i felt man
i would i wanted to make my life about
something great you know
and and i learned two things i mean one
one when you when you're close down i
mean you die alone there's nobody there
with you yeah so it's a very personal
thing it's about you know
what do you what do you want to be
thinking about on your way out what do
you what is the
energy the feeling that you have in your
body and it isn't about anybody else or
what anybody else thinks about you
mm-hmm it's about what you think about
yourself
and so
at that point i literally gave up
everything i owned
i had a company that uh
you know a major little company in the
cable television industry and but i i
ended up giving everything away kept a
a two and a half suitcases of personal
belongings minimalists yeah
i remember carrying him out and putting
him in the rv
sold the home sold everything wow
and and awesome but i wanted
i wanted freedom
i wanted to be free but more importantly
i wanted to be able to do something with
the rest of my life that wasn't about
making a buck it was about doing
something that next time i die i can at
least feel happy
about myself that i was here did you
enjoy this standalone patreon highlight
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
slash the minimalists or click the link
in the description your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
percent advertisement free